[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link and I'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting we are catching up with one
another and with you about our recent
trips that we took I went uh to Florida
for parents weekend to visit my freshman
and college son this is this was your
first
um visit since you dropped dropping them
off at College yeah that's a that's a
big deal that's a milestone moment
uh you Jesse and Shepard you all went
yeah we decided to not leave our 14 year
old alone
and to bring him with us
uh which ended up being an interesting
choice I mean we would have never not
done that but I just have a POV on that
normal Choice became very interesting
well I have a POV on what it's like to
hang out with a 14 year old
I would hope you do that uh you might
find interesting and you uh you had a
little bit more uh uh pleasurable trip
oh yeah definitely Christy and I had a
getaway
to Big Sur about this time last year I
believe it's when we went to Big Sur
um so I'm not going to rehash
there were there was a decent amount of
overlap last time there was a lot of
rain on the tin roof of the cabin
none of that this time uh but still a
bunch of beautiful trees
but there were a couple of things that
happened
um a person that I met that I could not
have predicted that I would meet deep in
the forest okay
and an encounter
an intimate encounter with unlike any
I've ever had
that did not really involve Christie
how's that for a teaser
I'm excited
um you actually look kind of tired you
know why I'm tired I mean that's the
thing we work hard man you know I I saw
I saw a few comments uh I can't remember
where it was I I tend to not read
comments and I find out why whenever I
do
um but back when you took a vacation and
then I took a vacation and we talked
about him on on on ear biscuits and uh
you know because we we are YouTubers and
because we like to be Sensational about
the way we title things
um in the way we describe things because
it's called entertainment uh we said we
called it worst vacation ever right and
then there were a few people who were
like I don't want to hear two Rich guys
complain about their their vacation that
they can afford to go on um
which I appreciate you know I I
appreciate that perspective but I just
want to remind you that um uh we talk
about these things for your For Your
Entertainment if you're not entertained
there's many other options oh on the
internet don't send a package please
don't go what else please don't do that
please like us what I'm saying is we
work very hard for your entertainment
and also for our the lifestyle that we
would like to live uh and that involves
doing things like going and visiting
your children when they go off to
college or taking your wife on a nice
little trip away we're not going to
apologize about those choices and when
we do them we're going to come back and
we're going to talk about them on this
podcast oh you have the privilege and
the freedom to comment about how you
feel like we're too uh privileged Rich
dudes who complain about things because
we are too privileged Rich dudes who do
complain about things for your
entertainment
um and we're going to continue to do
that we'll complain about the things
that are uh that bug us and we'll
celebrate the things that please us and
you're welcome to come along for the
ride uh but we're going to do what we
want to do that's one take I think the
other day like it
is uh you know I'm like oh I'm cringing
inside because like I'm very
self-conscious about like
okay uh you know having money
you know it's a hang up of mine like I I
really I wasn't planning on talking
about this but you talked about how I
look tired and the reason I look tired
is because I'm a middle-aged man who
works his ass off
running a company and then you feel like
you have to apologize for complaining
about your vacation which you only did
for entertainment purpose right right I
get that I totally get it I am not
disagreeing uh it
you know that there is something about
the evolving relationship that we have
with mythical Beast uh casual fans I'm
making a list now just um interloping
commenters you know and uh
sometimes it so there's like different
categories of people that we can get
feedback from sometimes you don't know
what like how to weight that feedback
so on one hand I don't want to be like
well I don't listen to any feedback
and I'm not saying that but
like I was telling you I was listening I
think we I think we demonstrated that we
listened to quite a lot we like a lot of
people yeah and take that into it if
anything a healthy exercise for us and I
think this is maybe what you're kind of
embodying at this point is that our
since our tendency is to be so
um sensitive isn't the right word but
there's a there's a high fidelity to the
give and take between us and
the vocal mythical Beast the feedback
that we get you know it is very
important it's very valuable if anything
we need to guard against overweighting
that
and not not going with our gut sometimes
or not being ourselves or saying I'm
doing this for entertainment value or
I'm doing this to reach somebody but it
can be misunderstood you know I agree
with that I was just telling you that I
was I I don't really listen to Joe Rogan
but Rick Rubin was a guest and like I
listen to everything that Rick Rubin
shows up on like I just like that guy is
so inspiring to me
so on the way in they were at a point in
their conversation where uh
he was Rick was asking
Rogan about like what kept Him grounded
and what you know despite experiencing
success and and fame what keeps him sane
I think it was less of grounded and more
of like sane you know
um because they were talking about
there's a lot that goes along with being
in the public eye being successful being
subject to so much scrutiny
and again I'm not saying anything about
Joe Rogan's point of view or stance on
anything
here but his response was
um
he works out
he does his cold plunge stuff which I
know you're getting into that too and
like so I I thought this would really
resonate with you and then he said I
don't
read what people say or think about me
at all yep at all yep that's a privilege
that that is that is a a wild privilege
you can do that as a really famous music
producer you cannot do that well no this
is Joe Rogan talking not Rick Rubin oh
okay so Joe doesn't listen to what
anybody says about it and it shows yeah
and it shows uh we're different people
than him so I think we approach him but
also if we didn't listen to anything I'd
like to think we're true enough to
ourselves and what we're putting out
into the world that that's what mythical
beasts are connecting with so that even
if we didn't listen to any feedback we
would still be in this safe zone of
we're still us you're still you we still
have this connection but
and I don't know I actually don't know
what the butt is
well I I I I don't know what my point is
so you tell me where I'm going I think
that there is a there's a difference
between accountability and like cowering
and fear right about being yourself so
for instance
we have a very we have a big team and
they do read all the comments and they
know exactly what people are saying so
it's not good the team is listening and
then telling us so the team recent
example
um we did an episode of GMM
uh where it was our can we follow
directions in a different language and
we decided to to we wanted to uh feature
American sign language on that uh
episode and we had a deaf person lined
up to be the person to do sign language
because again representation is
important to us and we were like we want
to get a you know a deaf person to
actually do this
they unfortunately on our team and by
the way our team knew that it's not
something we needed to tell them like
the GMM team already knew that so that's
what they were working on of course you
know it's like we it's not something we
had to like well make sure you do it
this way yeah and so they were going
about it in a way that I feel good about
that person uh was unable to make it and
of course our production schedule is
crazy and very tight and so uh Matt
Carney's friend was in town uh who you
know you you saw the guy who was on the
the episode and he his his brother was
deaf and he had to learn the whole
family had to learn sign language in
order to communicate with the brother so
we were like oh that's a cool story and
it's not exactly what we wanted which
was a deaf person but we made a decision
to still move forward with to be able to
have ASL featured on on the show and of
course we got immediate feedback uh from
a number of people about how uh this was
not inclusive to the deaf community
um and you know what we totally
understand that and and we we we listen
to that feedback and I think that you
know I think moving forward it'd be like
okay even though we know the back story
which is we had somebody who was ready
to go who was deaf and then we ended up
using a non-deaf person or a hearing
person uh
because that's a difficult thing to
explain and contextualize and we did run
the risk of making the deaf Community
feel excluded maybe we should have taken
a different attack and this is great
feedback and we'll take it into account
moving forward and we commented on the
people on Twitter to the people on
Twitter who said it we commented on a
tick tock video that's accountability
and that is something that we listen to
but me being a person of privilege and
wealth because of all the success that
we have garnered for reasons that are a
lot just we're just very fortunate very
lucky and right timing and things have
gone right
um and we do live an unusual lifestyle
um but that is the life that we live
that is the life that we have found
ourselves in is being the CEOs of this
big company that's doing well and having
figured out this internet game and
having the ability to work really really
hard all the time but didn't take much
needed breaks and then come on this
podcast and talk about them
um I understand that if you are not in a
situation where you can afford vacate a
vacation or you don't have a job that
pays well you don't have a job that you
even enjoy then it may be difficult to
listen to us to say that we do enjoy our
job and we do make a lot of money and we
do go on vacation and again what I'm
saying is you have the right
if that's like if that's triggering for
you to not listen but I'm not going to
not talk about my life because my life
might be triggering to you
and I just think that there's a place
where you have to draw the line I want
to be sensitive to it and I don't want
to make this podcast all about two Rich
guys talking about all the rich guy
stuff that they do because that would be
stupid but if you and we don't do that I
don't I don't I don't think but we but
the podcast is about our lives I mean
that is that is it yeah
ourselves and so I'm not going to
apologize for being myself but if we say
something but we are two middle-aged
dudes from rural North Carolina who have
changed a whole hell of a lot over the
course of the past 20 years and there's
still things that we're learning there's
things that we don't know and so when
our more informed more sensitive
audience lets us know where we've missed
the Mark we do listen but I don't think
that two guys talking about their
vacation and if I had a bad vacation
complaining about that vacation that's
not that's a place where I'm not gonna
let people bully me into not talking
about it that's all I'm going to say
about that I was thinking the same thing
this morning when I was brushing my
teeth with ground up diamonds
you know I found that like the abrasive
properties of the most expensive uh
diamonds
um
really do a great job cleaning my teeth
yeah I found that as well link right of
course you're using my leftover diamonds
uh
yeah because because I'm a cheapskate
because I get them first right yeah I
buy them off of you because out of them
in my mouth I don't I don't pay I don't
pay retail I mean my children use that I
am still a cheapskate I am how do so
this is how we started this podcast yeah
well should we just keep going should
the whole podcast be about like because
you know you know why on your feedback
you know why it shouldn't be because
there's a lot of people and I see you
and I respect you who are like guys you
should you don't have to talk about this
we don't care I understand that yeah I
appreciate you that you don't feel the
need to comment but I'm just you know I
wasn't planning on talking about this I
was going to give you guys a bear update
which I'll move on to now should we talk
about vote like a beast first yeah
because we should I mean if we want to
make this more controversial let's let's
tell them who to vote for
okay well we don't do that no um we did
create vote like a beast.com and the the
midterm elections are extremely pivotal
don't underestimate your local state and
the national midterm election what is it
November 8th so rapidly approaching we
create a vote like a beast to not tell
you how to vote but to help you become
informed in how you want to vote you
know you can you can check your
registration you can get all your
Affairs in order and you can in terms of
your point of view so that you can be
educated to vote your heart mind soul
toenails whatever it is you vote with
vote like a beast.com
go for it I
um
okay I recently talked about my trip me
and my trips
um
where Jesse and I went with friends
Lance and Lacey to a cabin
uh for the weekend and there was a bear
that bear drove your car getting into my
car
uh apparently
um
there is a bear Network
they are communicating with one another
and at least one of them listens to this
podcast oh this is my theory what this
is my theory because you will not
believe so far it sounds sound Theory
what happened to me
as you know uh we live in Los Angeles uh
and we live in relatively close
proximity to mountains that contain
wildlife
you've had encounters with bears oh yeah
yeah uh but I've never had an encounter
with a bear at my trash can in fact in
the dark I had a Face-Off with a bear uh
on my way back uh
from the airport
um the the Uber driver was
saying as he came up into the
neighborhood was like
uh uh you guys ever see Bears up here
as I was coming back from you know my
tripacy lot and I was like nah I mean
our good friends who you know live about
a mile away or so like they they've seen
them but we've never seen bears and I
was like as a matter of fact I've never
seen a bear
outside of the zoo because even the bear
that I had an encounter with I didn't
see you just saw Lance and Lacey saw the
bear and then I saw the evidence of the
bear
in the car and on the porch they put
that the uh sanitation people can give
you a special trash can that is bear
proof that that's how pervasive Bears
can be at certain times of years year in
certain times of the year in our
neighborhood well interesting but yeah
so I kind of assumed that you'd seen a
bear too your house like the back of
your house is like you know touches a
wildlife area where a bear could be at
home I'm more in a like an insulated
neighborhood with like rows of houses
around me so right which is why I'm
better than you right and so I always
thought to myself
when my trash can gets knocked over I
was just picturing
like three raccoons standing on top of
each other or something hey they can do
it they're so smart and cute uh but my
vicious my trash can has been knocked
over a few times and then the trash has
been rummaged through but I was just
like this is like a real smart raccoon
because I've seen a bunch of raccoons
well Jesse and I are coming back from a
birthday uh dinner that she had for me
uh which I will tell you about later
the other night and oh is this the
tortilla picture yeah that was tweeted
I've got way more pictures than that oh
yes
and we're pulling up to our driveway and
there's a little space in between our
driveway and our neighbor's driveway
their their house is currently like
under renovation and the driveway has
got all kinds of crap in it like just
from stuff they tore away from the house
and stuff
and walking down the road in front of my
house is a giant bear and I don't mean
like the one you taught me about told me
about was like a juvenile Bear right
this was a fat
giant bear like I don't know how to
estimate bear size but 500 pounds like
it was
massive uh yeah I have not seen a bear
that big and so I immediately and he
walked what time of night was this 10
o'clock
9 30 maybe wow
uh and he walks up the neighbor's
driveway and I immediately of course get
out the phone I actually wanted to get
out of the car but just so you didn't
let me
uh but this is this is the video that I
captured and prepare to be disappointed
because you know I was I pulled up as
far as I could in the driveway and then
got this oh it's like a
he's Carnage in their driveway
oh my gosh
are you getting him yeah he's huge he's
real big he's real big he's real big
she's from Fuquay I'm gonna tell you
right now
that is a big freaking Bear yeah it's
hard to tell that was just his head it
was just his head
yeah I would say he's the third bigger
than the bear that I had to face off
with in my backyard one time so now the
only animal that I haven't seen that I
know is in the neighborhood is mountain
lion
I haven't seen a mountain lion seen a
lot of I've seen a good amount of
long-legged bobcats in a whole lot of
long-legged coyotes you know Bobcat at
the creative house
yeah I've seen deer all the time I love
seeing a bobcat that's cool that was the
first bobcat I've ever seen first and
only mountain lion isn't that crazy
though
I mean my neighbor's seen some of those
so anyway now you gotta be you think
they're talking to each other all I can
say is I have not seen a bear up until
this point I talk about bears publicly
on the internet and Bear shows up and he
had been you know I mean I'm not a
detective but I believe he had been up
to my trash
to inspect it
and we hadn't put anything in the trash
yet it was that he he's not following
along he's not following the schedule
very well we've been out I always I
always forget when to put the trash out
too I have a reminder
and that is a reminder then tell my son
yeah that's what I need that's his job I
just look at when all my neighbors put
out their trash cans while I'm driving
in
um
so leaving for the trip sometimes the
the most important part of a trip is is
going and sometimes that's really
difficult to do
you know I think back to that RV trip we
had where like getting out of my
driveway was literally a test of Will
and human Ingenuity you remember that
um
I'm a big fan of filling up with gas the
night before last thing you want to do
is like pack up get really excited to
get on the road and then you start
getting on the road and you realize we
got to start we got to stop for gas
before we get on the road there's
something like it's like a stutter is it
a dad energy is it a man thing is it
I don't know what it is about like I
don't I want to get on the road I want
to get going like let's get going
there's a lot of standing around the
house like
you ready
you ready I've packed everything last
night
I packed it in my brain the night before
you know kind of a thing but this is
just you and your wife it's just me and
Christy so and she's pretty on board
with I imagine that she she packs well
in advance I I'm dealing with my family
man it's a war zone you know your
neighbor's driving I'm the least
organized person uh in our Duo but I am
by far the most organized person in my
family and so I like yeah I don't I
packed it I don't have it nearly yet
Christy and I are very we're we're very
much on the same page but
I will say she didn't fill up the gas
the day before we were taking her car so
I had to pull over and fill it up
at the bottom like before we like one
mile into the trip I'm like let's just
get it out of the way because once we
get going I just want to be going
and thank goodness we did that because I
don't have a little lever inside of the
car that you pull to open the gas cap
it's you just walk up to the gas cap on
the outside
and you push it you push it in and then
it opens the flap opens and there's no
cap and there actually is still a cap
underneath oh interesting in our car
um I pushed on the thing nothing
pushed on the thing nothing pushed
harder on the thing I could I couldn't
get it open
now we had half a tank of gas
but I wanted a full tank of gas and you
want the ability but more importantly I
want that ability
and I'm like oh gosh I think I'm glad
we're still here across the street is
the guy who uses our who who does our
service on the car and Chrissy's like
well take it take it over to him maybe
he can pop it
we take it over there and like he can't
pop it
and he's like well just leave it with me
and I was like well we don't have
another car that we we're going on a
trip we don't have another car that we
can take and we start taking everything
out of the back of the car so that he
can he can see if he can get access from
the inside to the back side of the
thing this is and I'm like I'm like yeah
it's just it's I'm and then I'm like
I just can't I'm looking so forward to
this trip I need this so bad like I
can't
this can't happen so like while they're
like rummaging through the inside these
two mechanics who are like stopping
everything they're doing to help us
because you know they they know Christy
because we get so much work done there
it's good to have a mechanic you can
trust and they know your face if not
your name and your wallet so
um I was like I can't I can't do this so
then I just I just started like wedging
my fingers in between like the door and
the fuselage of the car and I'm like
something has to be done like
something has to you're prying at this
point I'm prying and it's pulling hard
and I was like pop like I just ripped
the outside of like the
the body part the smooth body part of
the uh gas cap thing
I just rip that whole sucker off the
door came off the door came off in my
hand but it was just the it was just the
facade of it so then underneath there's
like this apparatus that the thing
that's actually broken that you have to
push on and then at that point they
could like take a
um
uh flathead screwdriver and pop that
open and then he said well because
there's a gas cap underneath it don't
don't push that thing all the way back
in and you'll be fine just like drive
with this thing just kind of like
flapping open a little bit so but
Christy and I both had a similar thought
we were like okay now we can get back on
the road we can get gas we went back
over and got gas and we're both
independently thinking the same thing
which is strange because I don't like
thinking this type of stuff because I
don't think I believe this way but I was
like is this a sign that we shouldn't go
on this trip wow okay
you know it's like how did that come up
we talked about a little bit later like
Christy was like
kind of feel well
we shouldn't go a bad Omen a bad Omen I
was like nope I'm not believing in Omens
this is not happening I believe in going
on this trip nothing else
but I got a little nervous
and then we're it's a six hour drive to
Big Sur
you know we we stopped for lunch
uh we get back on the road we're driving
uh a little bit further and then I'm
like you know what
let's switch so you can drive
you can drive a little bit we're about
to hit the curvy stuff she gets real car
sick so it's like driving should help
right a pullover
on the side of the road basically in the
middle of nowhere like we were about to
lose cell service again thank goodness I
pulled over where we did
because
the moment I got out of the car
to then switch sides the car just died
completely like all the power just died
like didn't car wouldn't crank you
didn't turn the car off it just I didn't
turn the car off it like knocked off
and and like I I don't know a 2018
Volkswagen Atlas it's not supposed to
knock off you know and
um so here we are on on this we're on
the PCH we're on Highway One like just
starting the scenic drive beautiful
you're so beautiful and we're like
sitting there like
I don't know what to do I feel very
um
inadequate
but then everything that Christie's
telling me doesn't make sense it's like
I do know I feel like what you're
telling me right now like can you like
put it in park make sure you've like you
try to use my key it doesn't see the key
it says that the battery's dead okay I
guess the batteries did but like while
the sudden would you just stop on the
side of road and the battery be dead and
like so we start fighting
like Chrissy and I never you know we
don't like raise our voices with each
other like we never yell at each other
but like
it quickly escalated on the side of the
road where she's like
call AAA
we can get him go ahead and call Triple
A I'm like I'm just going to sit here
and think I need to think for a second I
need to gather my thoughts he's like
well you can call AAA and then think and
so that way we're waiting even less and
like she's making good points at this
point and she's like but then I ended up
doing this thing where like she was like
just what
I'm trying to help and I'm like I'm
trying to help I'm trying to help it's
like this is how this is how toddler I
got like I was just so it was just like
feeling like this is ruining our trip
I am totally inadequate to fix this I am
I just felt I don't know it was just
like I felt like I was really in my head
and this is all an excuse because
there's no good reason and like half of
it was and I told Christy like 10
minutes later
once everything was resolved I was like
it was so funny how we were yelling at
each other I want to let you know that I
was like halfway joking I thought it
would be funny
you told her that you were joking that I
was halfway joking because I was I was
like I don't
know I know what to do it's like I was
yelling like that like literally it
wasn't like it wasn't like I was angry
at her and she was yelling too and then
she like just went to the back of it was
she joke was she joke yelling she was
like joking I mean a little bit too
it was one of those things where it was
just like because it was just funny that
we were on the side of her yelling and
and Chrissy texted us at this point it
was a part of us that knew that so it
wasn't like that's why I'm not
embarrassed to tell the story because it
was so embarrassing at the time because
it was just silly well she texted it it
didn't get that
no one was about to cry she just went
but she was like fine I'll just go to
the back of the SUV and I will just
stand there you know if you think you
got this we called AAA
and they came and they uh they charged
the battery
it was that simple
what did she text you at that point
because she wasn't talking to me that's
under me
oh well she the first text she sent was
not to our
uh you know our four-way text because
she didn't want me to see what she was
saying about me uh so let's see what she
said
it was probably just me and Christy
and Jesse
I don't know I can't find the text but
it was essentially
uh
you know we're on the side of the road
yelling at each other right now
she didn't say joke yelling I will I
will say the moment
she did not say that you were after the
guy it was the type of thing that like
neither one of us had to apologize like
it didn't get that real you know it was
this kind of like ridiculous joke
yelling type thing it's like
leave me alone you know and the guy AAA
showed up Triple A showed up alternator
the nope the battery was completely dead
and come to find out like
uh
uh we just needed a new battery
they can do that right on the spot but
they did for some reason they didn't
have your battery no they didn't they
didn't say I need a new battery but like
Christy has since taken it into the
dealer and by the way me ripping off the
outside of that gas cap helped a lot
three hundred dollars oh okay
that was a three hundred dollar yeah
cars man
but um so they just jumped you at that
point because they got you going because
apparently the the part that I ripped
off the the manufacturer just ships you
uh an unpainted one so you have to
install it that could be cool and then
and then and then you have to get like a
paint a body shop to paint just that
thing or you could leave it unpainted
and call it a joke a joke cover
a joke [ __ ]
this is my joke guys so we're adding
this to like my gas hole stories like
I've had some I've had some really
embarrassing [ __ ] stories over the
course of my career you can look those
up you have had you have had a lot of
issues with that car though yeah we got
to get rid of it because I mean it could
be a lemon because I don't I mean I
don't know anything about I don't know
much about cars or car brands or which
one I gotta get like a rolls
yeah and the ones that run on diamonds
yeah yeah the diamond burning rolls
and then we can just make a whole
podcast about your roles yeah you see
where I'm going so I at that point we're
like should we turn around
should we turn around because if we get
to the place where we drive three more
hours is the is the battery gonna die
again all he did was like charge it back
up and it had something that's what I'd
be worried about and I was like
especially on that road I was like yeah
because there's no cell service for the
next like two and a half hours and then
you finally get to the place you're
going it was like we cannot stop the car
we cannot get out we cannot do anything
until we get to the place we're going so
that then somebody can jump us again if
in order to get back home yeah some you
have to like basically slow the car down
and then you get out of the car and
Christy puts her hand on the wheel and
moves over and then you go use the
bathroom and then she comes back and
does the same thing the car never stops
that's how you do that we didn't I just
drove and neither one of us used the
bathroom okay or just be in your pants I
held it but
it turned out not to be a bad Omen
because everything else was great and
even the battery was fine for the rest
of the time and now it's been completely
fixed so don't worry about me because
I'm totally I'm not
so no bad Omen because we tested it we
went forward we pressed on two signs
that we should turn around we thumbed
our nose out of and it all worked out
yeah I agree I I don't I don't really
believe in Omens as well it's just like
you know you're starting out on the uh
uh I started watching that 1883 on the
plane
um which I think you would you've
already started getting a great watch I
watched it all it gets better well it
starts great so if it gets better Count
Me In man oh good I loved it right from
the get yeah uh Jesse will like it too
uh yeah I ended up watching all five
episodes that they had on the plane
without her up uh and I was like you can
catch up but I'm I'm all in for Tim and
Faith man anything they do I'm in and um
it's so good but Sam Elliott of course
you start the uh you start on the Oregon
Trail you're gonna you're gonna lose
some people right at this right in a
spoiler alert some people gonna die I
didn't realize it was the Oregon Trail
until um they were on a trail to Oregon
seven episodes in I was like oh yeah
everything that happens in this video
right exactly yeah uh
but you can't just stop because it's
gonna be hard man can't just stop
because it's gonna be hard you gotta pop
that [ __ ] yep uh I had an interesting
car situation uh I think last time I
told you uh last time we went to visit
Locke there was a issue with the rental
car company we had reserved a large SUV
in order to house everything that we
were moving him in with yeah things that
had been shipped down there and we're
putting it all in
so uh we requested just a mid-size SUV
this time for me and Jesse and Shepard
and then lock to be able to take him
around we show up at the rental car
place and just like last time and I'm
not going to be one of those
guys that complains about a specific
rental car company or an airline the way
that some people would a Twitter
following will do I just I'm you know I
get it but
I'm not going to do that I have I have a
lodged I found out that it is logic
complaint you stick it in the crevice uh
I have lodged my complaint with this
company as I waited in line to find out
that the reason that everyone was
waiting in line instead of just
immediately going and getting into their
car like usual was that they didn't have
enough cars but what they did have was a
whole lot of minivans
I mean minivans Embrace days nobody
wanted them well I go to like the lot
like he's like sir you're in spot j23 or
whatever and I go over there and that's
when I realized that they've got like no
cars but 40 minivans I don't know what
they think everybody in Miami Miami
that's where we were uh wants wants
minivans because it doesn't feel like a
very minivan place
uh yeah but
can't be beat I gotta tell you cannot be
I am just more and more appreciating the
minivan you know and I it's funny
because I'm moving into this stage of my
life where I don't really need one
because the kids are leaving
but I think I might be our first empty
nest purchase might be just a minivan
for me and Jesse
I know that there's so many ports that
is not true there's so many ports oh and
you know what they said sir we have
either a convertible or a minivan a
convertible minivan they the only
choices they had convertible why don't
you get a converter or minivan well
because
I didn't have any I have a there's a
family of four that I'm taking around in
this thing yeah okay all right
Shepard was not happy about this
Choice
he wanted the convertibles also you know
it was forecasting to be raining like
most of the time most of the days it was
going to be raining at least part of the
time so
but when faced with a minivan or a
convertible I mean that
those are the two ends of the spectrum
when it comes to car choices it should
make it I felt like I think you made the
right choice in a dream you know this is
not the kind of thing that you should
have to make a decision about at a
rental car place or we have the most the
coolest vehicle and the most uncool
vehicle which kind of person are you you
know form or function that's not a dream
I'll tell you a dream okay
Christy tell me uh we were on our trip
and she I was like how'd you sleep last
night because when you don't have kids
around and you're just like just
drinking your coffee and enjoying each
other you can ask things like how'd you
sleep last night
and she's like well I had this weird
dream that I I I I had to pee
and
uh I actually
I was afraid part of me was afraid I was
gonna pee in the bed but like I started
peeing and then I realized I wasn't on a
toilet I was on a hamster cage
no
she said I was peeing on a hamster oh
and it drowned
killed a hamster with her piss and she
said I she said it it had an it had a
napkin over it
after it died no she like slowly pulled
a napkin over it won't anybody see that
she said I looked down and like you had
a he had a soft and wet napkin over it
I guess it was like snuggling in his bed
no I don't believe in Omens but I do
believe in dream interpretation
that's a dream my friend she killed a
hamster
by Drowning it in her urine
that is some hardcore like I I mean I
ain't yelling at her on the side of the
road anymore you know what I'm saying
there's no joke yelling you know are you
the hamster yeah
yeah I mean I could be there are you on
a hamster wheel you're just endlessly
running and working and grinding
yourself down to nothing and she's like
the only way to stop this pattern is to
pee on him
is I don't we had no interpretation we
were just too baffled by that's a dream
not convertible minivan but all right
well here's the thing when we picked up
lock uh well actually lot came over to
the hotel that we were staying in which
was pretty close to campus
uh we got in pretty late
and we were actually just expecting to
see him in the morning because that's
what we had talked about but once we
because of like 10 o'clock when we got
in
he said I want to see you guys so he
comes over and
you know it's been what a month or so
since he's been since we dropped him off
not long enough in my opinion If the
fall break comes the parents we can
comes real early too quick but I think
the whole idea of it is
I think there's multi you know this is
multifaceted but I think one thing is
just like we should get the parents in
there pretty early so they can like
check on these kids before they really
derail themselves you know
uh they still got time to correct course
before they've dug too big of a hole
which a freshman can tend to do in that
first semester well yeah it's like we
moved uh
well you know what I'll keep this
anonymous
I might have moved one of my kids into
college for her second year and then
like the next morning we went back to
see her and like she was like you're my
Lily don't come in don't come in our
apartment because there's vomit all over
the rug
all right she's living that life
it wasn't hers okay
yeah but somebody threw it Christy was
like I brought that rug
just just weeks ago
this last night oh just last night yeah
cause we moved her in oh wow it was a
fresh rug
just testing it out oh my God a little
pin on the hamster if you will
oh man I'm throwing it I'm throwing my
whole family I've seen this episode I'm
gonna get I'm gonna get stronger well so
the the the general report is Locke is
doing great he's he is enjoying himself
he's doing well in school but he's still
very much lock which is a guy who is
filled with
um so many ideas that come at you in
Rapid succession that's your fault and
automatically it is it this here's the
mistake that I made right I was kind of
gearing myself up and I'm I'm going to
say this by way of lesson learned and
then maybe advice to other parents out
there
we talk often about
the goal being to maintain the
relationship right preserve the
relationship like that's Paramount
it's more important that you have the
relationship than you have
control right and there's an illusion of
control and even when your kid is at
school you still see them and even
because they're even if they're 18 you
still see them as your child that you
have power and influence over and you
care about them and you want the best
for them and so when they come at you
with a bunch of ideas that it wasn't
that it was just the way he was seeing
things and things he was going to
thinking about doing and there's like a
slow down and like tree I immediately he
like triggered dad mode in a hard way
and I wasn't expecting it because I
wasn't even expecting to see him that
night I was going to see him the next
day
and
we very quickly returned to a dynamic
that often manifests itself in our
family which is
Lock's talking a million miles a minute
about all the things that he wants to do
and all the things that he's thinking
and Jesse and I both go into Mom and Dad
mode where you're like trying to like
give advice and course correct and
uh it ended up being not a great initial
reunion now it ended well that night and
we hugged said I love you or whatever
we'll see you in the morning and gonna
go eat somewhere
but the first thing I did when I sat
down with him in the morning I was like
I want to apologize for
how I was reactive to you last night
when we when we talked and I feel like
we started the trip off on a bad foot
and you know I don't want that to be the
dynamic between us I trust you believe
in you love you whatever
it actually was that was good that was
very helpful not it's still the
McLaughlin's and so everyone has an
opinion and everyone is passionate about
their opinion and everybody thinks that
they're equally right
and Shepherd now
is is he's a whole thing in and of
himself as a 14 year old
um which the best way I could describe a
14 year old boy
and at least the one that's in my house
is it's as if someone
suddenly got
like they got turned on like slow motion
was turned on it was like you're it's
like you're watching a YouTube video and
then all of a sudden you put it on hubs
and everything slows down and gets
deeper that's what's happened to Shepard
he's got he's been stretched from a boy
to a man I I was I was watching uh the
video where we took him out in the FJ
and and during one of the Vlogs and kind
of like let him drive and he's like his
voice is so high he's sitting in my lap
at this point Shepard is six feet tall
uh like his voice sounds he's my
freaking height his voice sounds exactly
like me so much so that so Shepard had
his own room at the hotel and we got
there late all the restaurants were
closed and so we just got some food from
from uh the hotel
and he was like Dad can I call and get
some food from the hotel I was like yeah
so he calls and then I call
from my room to get me something to eat
and then the first thing I said was
didn't you just call ha and I was like
no that was my son so our voices sound
the same now so that little boy that was
on my lap just a couple of years ago is
now this big man but still a boy right
he's a boy man
right he's a boy
and he's moving in slow motion he's
entering into the conversation I think
he's becoming an end
and
um
boy getting him up waking a 14 year old
up
you know
so we had to have a discussion a lengthy
discussion about what sound he needed to
pick for his phone to make in order to
wake him up because he sleeps through
multiple sounds
there was an alarm there was me calling
his hotel room phone there was me going
down there and banging and then finally
I was able to get him up and be like
dude we gotta go eat
um but despite the fact that he has
become a Moy and is moving in slow
motion he is still a McLaughlin and that
comes out when we sit down and somebody
just it's so funny
um
because this is not this was not the
dynamic of my family like the dynamic of
my family was my dad would kind of say
something and everybody would just kind
of agree with it you know that was sort
of how my family worked the dynamic of
Jesse's family is that everybody has an
opinion in everybody is very good at
debating and it's just like hey guys
we're just talking about like
uh what we're eating right now like that
doesn't have to become a debate but the
way they actually show love to each
other is by entering into
debate and so Jesse kind of has that in
her
and then I can adapt to either situation
I can be like I'm along for the ride or
I also have an opinion and I can defend
it and so the dynamic that has emerged
in our family is that we go out to eat
like brunch
and we were in this restaurant and we
realized that we're talking very loud
and everyone's talking very passionately
about whatever they're saying and it's
like I feel like people are now like
like realizing how loud we're being and
like so definitely definitely um
but we actually we had a chance to kind
of like have the meta conversation about
the way that we because if anything like
said was it's just amazing how quickly
the our Dynamic returns yeah you know
like this is this is the way that we we
interact and so well that's that's
comforting well if he's like it's a
little bit frustrating but also
comforting at the same time but we
talked about our Dynamic and we were
like
um you know we need to believe the best
about about each other we don't need to
there's certain topics that we might
bring up that we disagree about that
there's just no reason for us to talk
about those things it's like this is
about connecting this is about figuring
out what you need at this juncture and
and you know us being there to be
supportive or whatever and then uh
we went to a football game
so
I was excited about this because we just
don't like we now that we're in
California and we're so far away from NC
State we don't if we still lived in the
Triangle we'd probably be going to like
NC State home games for not all of them
maybe but I definitely would be I would
be going I have some music when you ask
me to go I'd have season tickets to the
wolf pack and I and I just I Love
College athletics I completely give
myself over to the to the Mania to the
completely inexplicable Mania especially
that my only connection to this school
now is my son's going there I am giving
them a lot of money uh so
I
and they were also playing Carolina
oh and football
great and so I was like I'm not gonna
have to go and watch Carolina beat
another team that I've now gotten
dressed up for like we like we went to
the student store we got the clothes we
like ready to go I'm like I'm completely
embracing this and yeah Carolina beat us
um but I also was so into it that I lost
my voice I'm still like that game was I
noticed on yesterday like Saturday you
know you were really harass me well what
ended up happening was there was this
crazy it was one of those things where
everybody started leaving because it
looked like it was over but then they
started coming back and then there was
this crazy onside kick that they got but
it turns out when they watched the
replay the guy had gone out of bounds
but when he got when they recovered the
onside kick before we realized that
there had been a violation
it was freaking nuts and that was the
point in which a series of yells that I
do not remember came out of me uh and
caused me to like lose my voice for
several not lose it but like be raspy
I'm still kind of there blew it out
um
so anyway that was a really good moment
and and lock was like I had so much fun
I've never had that much fun at a
sporting event
um we ended up having a very very sweet
time
as a family
and then when we were leaving
Locke was like this is almost harder
than when you guys dropped me off huh
um got to meet like his friends and the
people he's connecting with you know in
his dorm
um there was lots of hugging and I love
yous and it was good so I like
we did the thing we did the parents
weekend thing
checked in
and I feel and and you know mission to
come we were already in very close
contact
in very frequent contact much more than
we were even when he was here when he
was living with us uh but that frequency
is even picked up since then with
multiple like texts a day I'm sure it'll
it'll die back down you know kind of
dies back down a little bit but the
relationship which again if if my goal
is preserving the relationship maintain
maintaining that relationship and that
mission accomplished
um you want to hear about the the person
I met in the wilderness yeah so uh we
were standing it's the same place we
stayed last year with had the cabins
Glen Oaks shout out to uh Glen Oaks got
cabins around the Big Sur River so you
don't you're in the forest you're not on
the like the Cliff's Edge scene the
ocean from from this particular point in
like the Big Sur Canyon but it's
absolutely amazing redwoods everywhere
uh these cute little cabins last time we
went they had shut down part of it
because there was a wedding
and
um so they do have weddings we we saw
some people walking around in tuxes like
our first morning there we had a full
day there
and then but we went down we found the
Adirondack chairs and just hung out next
to the river
and it was just it's absolutely
beautiful I took my took my shirt off
getting a little vitamin D like very
comfortable how warm was it and um it
was it was probably 70 degrees it
couldn't have been more perfect
which is chilly to take your shirt off
if you're me but like the sun was just
giving you that nice giving it the D Man
yeah and um
at certain points I just you know I I
have this
I like to be to myself I like to connect
with Christy and then at other points
I feel this need to want to connect with
other people like I like
I like sometimes it's so out of
character for me but sometimes I get to
a point where it's like I like having
conversations with strangers like when
we go to breakfast and I'm like oh what
do where are you guys from I don't know
you think this is out of character for
you sometimes
like when I go on a retreat sometimes oh
I don't want to talk to anybody
but I sometimes I'll get in that mode
it'll get in that mood like I saw a
couple come down to the river below us
and the guy was dressed up like he was
going to a wedding I guess this wedding
that was happening and then he was
taking a picture of his girlfriend and
like I was sitting there shirtless and I
was just watching them and I was like
you know what
I kind of want to go down there and be
in the picture with her I just think
that it you know I just think it would
be funny well yeah funny is one word
like funny for me
ding ding ding like totally yeah you
know how I am like I love the funny for
me humor and I was like I and I'm
telling Chrissy this I'm like I'll also
take a picture of them together because
he's just taking pictures of her he
looks nice
and she's like no don't you don't need
to be social with them thank you Christy
and they were a little far away but he
did turn and look at me and I waved at
him okay and he did not wave back yeah
because it's a little strange which I
took it to mean that uh Christie was
right and then she pointed the other
direction and there's like a foot Bridge
crossing the river and this is like 300
yards away
you know I know you're into football so
you know how far that is
um do you think it was three football
fields away
300 yards
three football okay fine two 200 yards
away because I mean that's almost a
thousand feet that's I mean some people
can't even see that far okay how far is
far enough that you can see someone
crossing a foot imagine yourself out the
way I think about this this is a
diversion I imagine myself out a hundred
yards Central High School field and I'm
looking across I mean you've heard you
played soccer you know they're one
football field away that sounds a lot
more reasonable
and it's like people in tuxes like
groomsmen Crossing this Footbridge and
then you found the wedding party the bra
and I was like oh there's the bride and
I'm telling Christy I'm like
that's the one I want to talk to
I want to talk to the bride
and I know that I know that I'm this is
putting Christy on edge and I'm just
being you know it's just funny to me
and uh she's like
rolling her eyes
and we're talking about the wedding and
how it's like it would be so beautiful
to get married here and stuff like that
we're almost talking ourselves into like
renewing our vows which I'm I'm against
my bowels are still very much intact
okay even though they were very
jesus-centric
in one sense you can make an argument
that we need some new vowels but like I
also feel like we're doing great there's
nothing to renew it's still it's still
going on isn't it just about the party
well we can have a party anyway okay
but then we're sitting there in the
chairs chilling out and all of a sudden
out of nowhere pops
this guy in a tux
the groom with a photographer behind him
how close is he how many football fields
I would say he is uh five feet away from
me okay that's very close I mean popped
out of nowhere and then I saw behind the
photographer the bride and I'm like oh
[ __ ] is on
it's time I get to meet this bride and
like the guy's like why he's like would
you mind if we kick you out
and it's like okay we're gonna take
winning photos and I was like oh yes yes
yeah and I like I was shirtless I felt a
little weird I'm like scrambling to put
my shirt on and he's looking at me uh
strange and then I was like well I know
I'm strange but he's like don't I know
you from the internet and I was like
yeah I was like I was like I'm getting
out of here I'm getting out of here you
guys take over he was like let's get a
picture so I get a picture with the guy
shirt on shirt off uh shirt is on at
this point and I'm like but I'm just the
bride's walking up she's very quiet she
did not say anything she's because she's
probably concerned and I'm like you look
beautiful congratulations
and then like all of a sudden there was
a teenager there and a baby and I'm conf
I'm I'm like all of a sudden I'm
confused is it insta family it's and I
started thinking because I was it was on
my brain that they were renewing their
vows
if for some reason I came this closer to
asking them are you guys renewing your
vows like wouldn't that be the stupidest
thing to ask someone who's like getting
married yeah yeah I didn't say it
because instead he said I'm from Naked
and Afraid
and I'm like oh what okay all right I
was like well we were already leaving
you're getting married you don't have to
drop the fact that you're in a reality
competition show where you're naked well
and surviving but
it's like okay but he knew you from the
internet so he knew me so he was I guess
he was trying to what did he look like
he was a um he was a tall strapping
bearded man middle-aged okay
did he look anything like me I mean you
said tall and strapped no bearded yes
because there's multiple people who have
I don't I don't watch Naked and Afraid
well I don't want to spoil it because I
think that the season's not out and I I
didn't ask him if he won or lost or
whatever or like was he a recurring
character is he just he's he hasn't been
on yet what do you mean a recurring
character it's just like Survivor I
think I think some people the best of
like come back oh I don't know and
people have said you're dropped in the
wilderness that I was on it you know
people who think that just a Tall
Bearded guy is always I'm sure there's
plenty of Tall Bearded guys on Naked and
Afraid yeah because I mean if you're
tall you're gonna end up bearded because
you're out there anyway you start tall
you're gonna become bearded yeah well
more than one beard you know right yeah
see all the Beards that's really more of
a mustache so that's the guy that I met
and then I'm like uh
did you ask any questions about the did
you talk to the bride I just kind of I
said you look beautiful she was like
didn't want to say anything so then we
just kind of left
they got married what did Christy say uh
she was just kind of like
she wasn't talking she was chewing me
out of there because I she didn't want
me to be too talkative
and um
yeah it turns out they got married and
then we're Chrissy and I are hanging out
for hours in our cabin
having a grand old time and then
we both had to use the restroom at the
same time
so I was like I'll just go down to the
there's a rest there's more of like a
cabin that is like public restrooms and
I'm gonna walk out of our cabin and go
there while you're in using our back she
uses the hamster yeah so then I uh once
I use the bathroom down there I was just
where at this point I was just wearing a
bathrobe and flip-flops
like nothing else
okay that's odd I mean I mean you are at
a resort but there is a wedding party
wondering well they are from naked and
afraid so
so I uh I kept once I exited the
bathroom instead of going back to the
cabin there was a path and I'm like I'm
just gonna walk this path down through
this beautiful Forest
and I found myself just like having this
contemplative time where I was just
enjoying nature walking around in my
stark white robe and my flip-flops on
this like little path
trying not to get poison ivy and all of
a sudden these two 14 year old boys Dart
around the corner wearing tuxes
and they like and they're they stumble
upon me and almost run me over and I'm
like I gotcha
so I talked to these it turns out that
this um boy 14 year old boy
uh a Moy I guess you would call him was
he moving in slow motion he was his his
dad
was naked and afraid dude who just got
married okay so he had been in the photo
shoot earlier so I talked to him for a
while did he did he recognize you uh he
did but I was he was like you're that
guy I was like we're all just people
how long have you known your friend here
we're all just people yeah and he was
like
um three years and I was like that's a
full third of your lives that you've
known each other of course that was not
not true not true I realized almost a
fifth right but I was just trying to I
was trying to give them something like
give them some perspective yeah
on life that you know it's like you gave
them some perspectives because like
we've known each other for like a third
of your nine years like 90 of Our Lives
we've known each other
maybe more than that and then you know
so I was just trying to give them
perspective it's like it's good to have
a friend
yeah it is it's great it's great to have
a friend but they were probably thinking
why is this naked dude in a robe talking
to me about incorrect math
how did this conversation go like what
did they say back to you and what did
they weren't they didn't want to be as
philosophical as I felt like I wanted to
be
um you know the forest tends to do these
things you know it's like I was on a
retreat
and they're getting I was like they had
already gotten married they they were
taking I was like you guys are running
from pictures aren't you like yeah they
want to take a lot of pictures I was
like you just need to party
don't worry about pictures that's what I
told him
they're going to tell their friends
about this interaction who knows what
the hell they're gonna say so then this
is like 30 minutes who knows what you've
done to the brand Christy
when I walked back up to the cabin
Christy was standing there in her robe
like with their hands like what the hell
where have you been like how long was it
you think half hour
20 minutes to use the bathroom yeah and
she was like I just knew that you were
trying to crash the wedding you were
trying to crash the wedding I was like
well no I wasn't I was just taking away
but we did get invited to the reception
so and they really want us to go
and because I saw the naked in Afraid
guy when I was coming back and he was
like come we're going to the reception
right now you guys should come I was
like well if I can talk Christy into it
we'll be there
and I'm just in my row I'm like I'm like
I like to party but I'm not really
dressed for the occasion
and I made sure that my junk wasn't
hanging out that's good
and then Chrissy when I told Christy
we've been invited to the uh wedding
reception
let's get dressed let's go right now and
she's like
did who invited you I was like Naked and
Afraid guy
and his son and his his brother
and she's like did the bride
and I was like well she was there she
was sitting in the car
waiting to leave but
I kept talking to Naked and Afraid guy
so they were kind of delayed but she
never invited me and Chris is like
exactly we can't go to their way we
can't crash their wedding reception and
make this about you yeah I'm like you
know what I respect that
so we didn't go I'm glad I'm glad you
have a wife she's so great
she she is my rock like if you if like
you did these things a lot she's my rock
she gives me freedom to
just go just to let loose I know that
she's there for me I feel the same way
about you a lot of times well it's a lot
of work yeah I I mean I mean listen I
don't go on I don't go on Retreats with
just you so
but God bless your wife she she I love
her to death she's amazing she needs a
raise she needs well I I I gave her a
raise
oh okay yeah
[Laughter]
um I love Big Sur man
I would just love to hear that story
from the perspective of any one of the
people that you talk to but most
especially the bride Christy said I knew
you were naked
and I was afraid huh she's brilliant and
then she was like you know what that's
what we should be for Halloween like you
can be naked and I'll be afraid that's
pretty good that's pretty good she was
like I can just be my you know she's
like and you know I I tend to be more
afraid about things
and you tend to be prone to want to be
naked about things
um
I you know
I I tease at the beginning that I would
talk to you about the uh the tortilla
margarita
that got posted on the internet so Jesse
took me out to a birthday dinner and we
were going to this place uh in La that
Jesse completely nailed the description
of it which is
it's a place that kind of embodies the
the thing that people think
Los Angeles restaurants are but actually
aren't okay meaning everything is
completely over the top and super showy
and it's sort of a you do this one time
and you probably won't come back this is
how I feel about it gimmick
gimmicky but in a
let me just I'll just take you through a
little photo photo essay and I will
describe these photos for those of you
who are listening so
uh it's just the two of us originally we
were going to take Shepard uh but he was
moving too slow
um let's just see he's I basically it
come become stationary
uh no he had like a bunch of homework to
do and he's like sorry Dad I've got too
much homework and we were kind of like
you know this will just be a date
between the two of us maybe even better
great have you said the name of the
restaurant uh it's called Barton G uh
and you know it's an experience like I
said uh the food was
was good
uh but it's not really about that it's
about
the presentation so it started off and
the waiter said this right up front he
was like
everything you order here is going to
kind of come with a little bit of a show
I didn't know exactly what that meant
but a little bit of a show I did pick
the I mean the first you order here is
going to have a tortilla so this is a
picture that my wife took of me in my
drink which it was just a margarita
um you know I'm honestly at this point
I'm very very happy I'm just content to
be with my wonderful wife at my on my
birthday and there is a tortilla that is
on top of the margarita like actually
um it looks like a it looks like a like
a an adult version of a kid's sippy cup
lid like you've popped through the
tortilla with the straw yeah this was
called the La Playa La playerita so it
you can't really see in the picture but
there's a picture frame below it and
it's sand and a starfish like oh we're
putting this Margarita on the beach on
your I mean not not too flashy just sort
of okay it's on this Frame and it's got
a tortilla okay all right I mean it's
odd and I did eat yes the entire
tortilla
had it did you
were you supposed to
um why not I mean it I believe it was
edible
so then uh we got a you ate it and
you're still saying I'm still open to
the fact that it might not have been
edible but I did eat it and now things
picked up a notch here when we ordered
the Caesar salad which was one of the
best Caesar salads I've had I will say
that I like a good Caesar salad
especially if it's real strong
and of course the Caesar salad came with
a bust of Julius Caesar as you can see
I'm
a little bit intimidated and perplexed
is that made out of cement it's uh it's
it's rock hard man oh man
um
and it's a little it is a little bit odd
to eat a salad while Caesar is at your
table it's just so weird it's like it's
not even part of the salad it's just
it's your statue you just wait friend
then we order the I actually went kind
of light on the number of things that we
ordered because okay you know so I so we
got that salad then we got a highly
recommended appetizer the lobster Pop
Tarts
that sounds good and as you can see they
come in a toaster right uh-huh
they were very tasty
but this Lobster was in there um did
they skimp no they actually went real
hard on a lobster I mean they didn't
skimp at all at this point I told Jesse
at this point I said that makes sense in
a in a toaster this is a something that
the mythical kitchen would make for us
on the show and B how they would present
it to us you know yeah and so I was like
I feel like I'm on my show now okay but
but not in a good way
no I I was enjoying myself but then
things got a little bit crazy because I
ordered
well you know what
I'm gonna come back to that because
because that's the kicker I ordered
something that was a little
underwhelming
um it was the fish is that on your head
or in front of him well Jesse thought
that this would be a cute way to take
the picture it's hanging it's a fish on
a rock that's on like a rod hanging over
a fish that you're eating it's so so
it's a little bit weird right a little
bit weird
uh fish was pretty good but then they
brought out the short rib and this was
three full beef ribs I actually have so
much of this left over because we didn't
put hardly a dent in it but it came out
um
on top of a lawnmower that took up the
entire table the entire table because
it's grass-fed so and here's a video so
that is a push lawnmower yeah here's a
video complete with sound
it's making a whole lot of noise the
lawnmower is making is taking the whole
table
and so and it makes a scene like it's
loud it's a lawnmower now there's like a
speaker inside of the lawnmower that's
making all this noise I don't I'm so I
don't
it's so easy to poo-poo it but I don't
want to just go there let me just say
as somebody who eats weird [ __ ] on the
internet for a living and has people
make weird things to bring it out in
yeah even I was beginning to get a
little embarrassed I and I don't like to
draw attention to myself but everyone at
the restaurant is drawing attention to
themselves over and over again because
that's the whole point of the restaurant
hey this lawnmower is coming out
multiple times you've seen the lawnmower
on other people's tables no actually I
saw it first for me but then we got
there a little early I guess but then I
saw it at multiple people's tables
actually wasn't that crowded I think
people in LA are maybe a little bit over
this concept we'll see it was also a
weeknight how did they put it on the
table did it take two people uh
yes but here's what they did they
brought it out they set it down
and then they come to you and they say
did you get your pictures or whatever
and then they take it away and they just
bring you back the meat because you
can't eat with that damn lawnmower it
takes up the whole table
at this point
we needed dessert and I told you and
Jesse was like
what do you want for dessert I was like
I want the the least embarrassing
dessert wow your spirit had been broken
yeah I was like I mean that says a lot I
mean because I had seen of dessert that
had a fork that was like seven feet tall
it felt like and
um and also I looked and they had a pie
it was just like this is a pie
the least embarrassing and uh I was like
what's the pie tonight and they were
like it's peach pie with ice cream I was
like yeah but what are you gonna do that
feels peaches it might might come out on
a big ass so uh this is that moment
so they gave you a birthday candle yeah
what is that it is a pie eating contest
trophy with the full pie you get a whole
pie and then they have multiple empty
pie plates
the way that Jesse gives commentary on
these videos is is the is this it's not
her gift
it's the running headline you bury the
lead here that like my wife will say
some funny stuff like she's like it's a
video do you want a photo
it's a lawn mower this is what our carne
asada came out no she does listen to
this podcast and she's gonna have words
with you I have to get I have to give a
[ __ ] about it it's hilarious so it says
fifth place on this photo and you get a
trophy and you get these empty pie
plates and again this is this is my
dessert it is a full pie
for two people so I I definitely think
if you want to have fun I I think the
Shepard have been doing what he's been
he would have been more embarrassed I
mean he's 14. now I think that this
could be a good group outing I do think
it's worth going out as a group because
again the portions are huge that this is
what we this is our profession though
that that the meat the short rib which
tasted great you gotta fed like five
people and of course a whole pie so I've
got I've eaten us we each ate a slice of
that and I've got like a whole pie in my
fridge now
uh we could go one of two directions we
can make fun of this or we could invest
in it you know it's like it's kind of
like the minivan
or the convertible well you know what I
one of the things Jesse and I talked
about when we were eating there was
um
I was like I don't think I would do this
again because it's you know
I get it I saw how it is I'm much more
interested in just eating good food at a
cool place
uh but it did make me think about some
of the things that we've talked about
years ago really pre-pandemic we talked
about like and people I mean have asked
us about this a hundred times like what
were the mythical restaurant look like
right you guys play so many games with
food and you've got all these crazy
ideas and what would it look like
um and so we've concepted some different
restaurant ideas that are you know
incorporate like playing with your food
but the thing that hit me
is
I think I would go to a place like that
and
it needs to be on a tourist trap it
doesn't need to be yeah it's you you got
to get people who are in the right mood
to be like I just don't got to be on a
pier I want to have an experience right
now and so you got it you're totally
right it's got to be in a place where
people are like we're here to have fun
we're not good witness here like I want
a good thing to eat in a people who are
saying what do we want for dinner well
been there Bubba Gump that what's next
you know what I'm saying well it's kind
of like the Rainforest Cafe yeah
which the food is not as gimmicky as the
the atmosphere which is very moldy and
it has definitely passed its prime and
the prime wasn't even that impressive
um I don't ever order the prime
um but I don't know it made me think
twice about that first of all I just
opened in a restaurant just feels like
a Fool's errand I somebody I am not
going to share I'm Gonna Save my store
given time I'm Gonna Save My Story of my
intimate encounter uh but I I do want to
leave you oh I thought so the the story
of meaning Naked and Afraid wasn't the
intimate encounter no he got more
intimate than that than being in a robe
was
on a trail well I mean
what are we talking about next week
what's on the docket we can give a
little teaser and I maybe I can add this
to it
oh the mythicon live episode comes out
next
all right so what we just experienced in
mythicon is our next episode what about
after that what do we plan on doing
all right maybe I can throw it in there
I don't know
or maybe we make it a car biscuit I
don't know we'll talk about but I do
want to leave you with I went first of
all I'll leave you with this picture
of me Christy took a picture of me in
the sunset holding a glass of wine she
told she told me where to look
so I feel like this should be the cover
of like AARP or something like you know
what I look like
it does have that bro it has a brochure
like it has a brochure like Vibe and I
like
I just look like I don't know
this is the same place that Jesse and I
got all of our uh our anniversary
pictures taken see there's me looking at
the sun setting that's not good enough
she said look to my left then I become
AARP material and we went on yeah it's
the same place that you guys went and we
went on this amazing
hike
and we we go to this you know there's
like
all of this um
ocean fog coming in up up the cliff and
then over the Redwoods and we're hiking
in this Meadow all of a sudden we come
out of the woods into this beautiful
Meadow and we walk around the meadow and
then I look back and the this the sea
fog or whatever it's called I took this
time lapse video look at that it that's
just like something out of you know out
of out of a Lord of the Rings spooky
horse chase scene I mean it's the most
beautiful place isn't that amazing I
mean Pixar's most beautiful place I've
ever I love it I love it so much so
that's what I'm Gonna Leave You with and
I'll I'll share I'll share that other
story at another time you can't we we've
packed so much into this episode and
you've made it
you've made it to the end unless we
pissed you off at the beginning and you
didn't and you're not here anymore and
I'm you know yeah you don't know you
don't know we're talking about you I had
I had fun I'm you know what I'm I'm
grateful
uh oh yeah forever grateful forever
grateful I'm forever grateful
uh I'm gonna give you a little wreck
you probably have heard of this uh
musician but I've been recently
introduced to her
um
Yola
you listen to Yola uh Yola yeah Yola
with an exclamation point ah
oh she is incredible
uh what type of music is Yola well as
she says on her Twitter bio she is
musically genre fluid
okay six-time Grammy nominee
I got introduced to her because people
were talking about and this is a this is
a very humbling some people were talking
about her and me in the same sentence in
terms of a kind of an approach to music
which uh hey I'll take it
especially with my first track on my
album Believe me which has that kind of
throwback she has this throwback
meets Soul Meets country at times and I
think that's where that's where the
conversation crossed over with me okay
she's got some really good country songs
uh I said oh her new album is produced
by Dan Auerbach uh from The Black Keys
and that's okay that's a great album my
suggestion is that you start with her
album walk through fire
and just that first song uh far away
look is just immediately like
this woman is doing something very very
special all right she is singing her ass
I'm gonna check this out and the
production is just is just wonderful so
Yola with an exclamation point oh she
appeared on the high women uh
collaboration album and the Elvis uh
yeah yeah she's in the high women
soundtrack with Brandy oh she she's not
into high women there's it's four
oh well she's my women is four white
women and she's a black one well but she
she's in that so she's in that she
appears the high women song okay yeah
he's got a man of shires and then Marin
Morris Brandy Carlisle okay all right
I'll check highly recommend all right
all right so walk through fire 2019. in
the meantime we will hey we'll be at
mythicon next time you're hearing from
us I hope to see many of you there hope
to have many of you join us for the live
stream
um no that's already happened oh yes
well I'm just saying that and and I'm
retro future at this point
thank you for those of you who joined us
for the live stream and join us next
time uh hashtag your biscuits188 earpod
one
hi this is Cassie my fiance and I will
be getting married in October 21st of
2023. a year from the day that I am
calling
I would love to invite Renton League
they've never done this so how about
being the first one to my wedding hi
this is Paige from Michigan and um I
just wanted to say on behalf of all
um you know Veterinary Medical mythical
beasts um we're so glad that you adopted
a dog
um and that you didn't buy a puppy so I
hope that you and Sean and Barbara have
a wonderful life just wanted to throw
that out there and give you a little
appreciation for that love you bye hey
guys
um I just want to say love you guys love
the podcast my boyfriend and I listen to
you all the time make sure we catch
every single new episode however we also
listen to you guys um GMM mythical
kitchen and ear biscuits as background
noise while we work from home so our dog
I heard this a similar caller had a
similar thing has really bad separation
anxiety but when we leave him the only
time he doesn't cry is when we put on an
episode of beer biscuits I think because
associate with like you guys being his
friends and being home with us I think
he thinks of you guys as like actual
people in his life and it's super cute
and it's something we've only recently
discovered but it's totally cured to
separation anxiety so thank you so much
all right have a good one
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
foreign
[Music]